well we might America name is TJ that's
much easier than I'll talk about the
non-aligned and what are they said
yesterday this Yugoslavia wasn't pressed
on the importance of Yugoslavia I
couldn't agree more with with that
though I have to say that there are two
important countries in the non-aligned
only 21 body goes valid and the other
one was India so without these two
countries nothing was possible you know
India was almost fifty percent of the
moon was bad bitch Yugoslavia was the
political motor of everything and these
two countries remain that in the
non-aligned goswami until the breakup of
Yugoslavia Indian still a member but
such a big country and has other
political agendas I guess the movement
of the non-aligned was already in Christ
is after the second summit which was
helping in Egypt in Cairo and he was
also were trying everything to do
something about that in 1966 in may of
nineteen sixty-six teacher went to
alexandria last time on his famous
historical ship gala neat Nasser I don't
know they met 22 times since Nasser
became head of Egypt and they decided to
have a celebration of the 10th
anniversary of the first meeting of the
big three of the non-aligned in India
the big three of the non-aligned ratito
Nasser and the Indian Prime Minister
mail and that meeting was held in
delhi with indira gandhi instead of
narrow that meeting was actually about
just about sending the message to the
third world countries where we are still
there you know they were not talking
about anything in particular you know
just sending the message if you're still
here you know still dealing with those
issues whatever he was Lobster at the
same time afraid of the initiative this
Cuban sponsored initiative at the
beginning of 1966 there was a meeting of
the organization of the solidarity with
peoples of africa asia and latin america
and that was directly contradicting the
Yugoslav idea of the non alignment which
and me there was no place or for
European country in such an such a
vision of the third world as Cubans so
after the meeting in New Delhi there
were a series of other meetings of the
business people from from the third
world countries mainly these tools
actually these two countries with a very
poor results though then the war of 1967
changed so many things Yugoslavia like
never before or never after 1948 linked
to the east Tito not only broke up
diplomatic relations with Israel but
went to Moscow on a meeting the Warsaw
Pact countries because fabia was not
part with the worst effect in order to
see how you go swabia might assist the
herbs in 1967 a total crisis of the
movement you know that lasted for four
for a year but in 1968 Yugoslavs for
again is it trying to revive
the prior to the Soviet intervention in
Czechoslovakia so I'll just read you or
try to quote a little thing from that
was said that the meeting of the joint
session of the presidency and executive
committee of the Central Committee of
the u.s. illegal communists 1968 when
Minister of Foreign Affairs nika such
pain ascertain politician actually
supported so appraised Soviet presence
in in the Mediterranean you know the
Soviet fleet came into the Mediterranean
and he both and Tito said well in a way
it's very useful to have the Soviet
fleet I wish them to be even stronger
that they are now visibly the Americans
that those Iquitos words immediately
said approximately the same but one day
the Americans will leave and then they
the soviets should leave to do a little
bit before that in early on night in
early nineteen in january of 1968 there
was a preparatory meeting in Rome of the
method for the Mediterranean conference
of the so-called progressive parties 17
part is we're supposed to participate
Italian communists were organizing dance
a meeting Yugoslavia was represented by
a front like organization which was
called the socialist socialist alliance
of the working people and you slob
platform the document you Muslims
presented became the basis for the April
summit though something changed in the
meantime there was a meeting of the
Communist Party's in Budapest one month
later and the Soviets managed to
persuade the French Communist Party
detailing Communist Party the side rails
to change up their minds so the meeting
held the Mediterranean
conference held in april of nineteen
sixty eight in rome finished with a
declaration which was not signed by the
useless because the Yugoslavs were
opposing what was missing from the from
the original draft was a sentence that
there must be a simultaneous elimination
of all foreign military presence in
mediterranean and the Yugoslavs verb
opposing that you know just Americans a
bad guys and that only the Americans
should leave the Mediterranean
interestingly enough raw death yugoslavs
for Tito repeated that's almost exactly
like that to present Nixon during his
visits to Yugoslavia in nineteen seventy
saying that when we say that to to the
Russians they get met and you are
insulted when we say that to you mix
them two Diesel's word said well we do
not say that as an insult we only think
that you cannot look at the Soviets in
our presence with the same glasses in in
the limited rain so it intervention in
Czechoslovakia in 1968 changed change
all dynamics because us valves were
really scared of
that's happened and the importance of
non-aligned for Yugoslavia became even
bigger you know we heard yesterday how
many small countries of the
Mediterranean a very ambitious
Yugoslavia was extremely ambitious
confetti there was an extremely
ambitious leader and after after the
second world war with his plans to have
a ball Confederation you know after
after that with a special path to
socialism you know he was also playing
that part but then the non-aligned
non-alignment remain the only
international podium for you go swap
ideas really and he became one of the
fundaments of the use of regime so the
idea some of the non-aligned countries
and some even of the very important
non-aligned countries like Ethiopia for
instance want you to have a conference
dedicated to the Soviet intervention in
Czechoslovakia that was not to be
because so many cancers opposed namely
Egyptian president again you know I'm
not going to participate in such a
conference because everything I get it's
coming from the Soviet Union but
nevertheless the attempt to organize
another summons which started by the way
prior to the Soviet intervention in
Czechoslovakia so it's not that the evil
sauce you know discovered what so it's
really mean you know and they've started
with preparations by details these are
sending letters to all participants of
the second 17 in Cairo eventually
happened you know in spite of as it was
set later Eric obstruction which was
defeated leftist radicalism which was
sub used with realistic from recive
solutions and some important country
is on the right especially asian were
moved to the positive positions once the
summit took place in Lusaka in Africa
while useless were trying to organize
that summit there was one Mediterranean
country that was opposing the original
idea to invite everyone who was
participating at the second summit and
that was Algeria Algerians were
supported by Congo Brazzaville Syria
Cuba somalia thought that all only the
most progressive countries should
participate and not everyone but as I
said you know arab obstruction was
defeated and there was a summit in
english side from that moment onwards i
would say for yugoslavia non-alignment
became everything in the foreign policy
so important that they thought how
President Nixon's visit to Belgrade
Zagreb and Petersburg places in the
cooler it was because of the success in
in Africa that's not true i've seen
documents from the college park which
you can find that nixon in his memo to
kissinger in his memo to President Nixon
wrote you know do mention or you can
mention the non-aligned otherwise not
important but dear to his heart that's
ninety seventy and you have another
conference in Algeria in 1973 and
another one in Israelite at nineteen
seventy seventy six but things were
changing because it seems found that
it's probably many other documents but
the only thing
I've seen our conversation between Henry
Kissinger and the Chinese in 74 and 75
where Chinese they open for instance was
questioning Americans about the cold
balkan peninsula Middle East region was
that part of an old strategy of the Czar
you know and then Kissinger refined both
in 74 and especially in 75 how we are
concerned about Yugoslavia that's why
Americans were selling military
equipment to Yugoslavia and that's why
if he personally went to use fabien plus
present forth in 1975 after the
conference in Helsinki it will not be
like Czechoslovakia integers rest once
again but Americans during this period
you know over interested probably more
interested in the security of Yugoslavia
but less interested in the non-aligned
they became nevertheless more interested
when Cuba or after humans became so
visible and so eager to take over the
movement you know after the successes in
Africa especially when humans became
candidates to organize summit in 1979
and Americans were paying much attention
to to the preparations of of the Sun and
sober Yugoslavs to determine four inch
Tito went to seven Mediterranean country
or 77
countries let's say Mediterranean
countries kuwait and iraq among those
Libya Algeria jordan syria and malta to
talk with their leaders to prepare them
for for the summit in in Cuba I'll just
quote what Yugoslavs got from through
diplomatic channels what Andrei Gromyko
said about details tour around
Mediterranean in 79 in early 79 so the
Polish party secretary yet and his
ministry of foreign affairs he toast or
among the Arabs was and I quote
objectively on the line of torpedoing
the Soviet influence and strengthening
of the non-aligned movement but under
the US left flank and that's actually
what what what happened in Havana in 79
and it wasn't easy for the US thoughts
because Egyptians were not helping at
all Egypt was not part of your Arab
League at the time and there was an
attempt to keep the amount of the
movement you know so not only that
Minister of Foreign Affairs didn't go
boutros boutros-ghali was representing
Egypt in in Havana favoring of trying to
fearing what what might happen but you
Slavs were opposing that as well as most
of the African countries unlike the rest
of the earth bro but what a managed they
managed to preserve the movement on the
so-called genuine line or ketones blind
I have to stop here then I can't start
that you on on
Afghanistan and what happened today they
managed to save the headsman but in 1979
after the Soviet intervention you know
you didn't have an orb or you why didn't
have even India behind them because they
wanted to condemn the Soviet
intervention in an online socialist
country like Afghanistan non-aligned
socialist and not part of the worst
effects just as Yugoslavia no no mine
social is not part of the worst effect
there was intervention they wanted but
Nolan for the first time ever to condemn
the Soviets through the mechanisms of
the known elements acting alone the
factor you know Egypt was not there
India was not there now being scared of
the the growing importance of Pakistan
you know so what they did and they
managed in a way they managed to have a
regular session of the non-aligned
organized a little bit before than it
was scheduled you know and there was a
mild condemnation of the Saudis but the
whole diplomacy around it was
fascinating i would say and of course
when you take like I can talk more about
that when you look at that then of
course the American administration
finally you know started to look at the
non-aligned as something that actually
might help or that actually might play
certain importance in the global arena
JD I owe 2015 15 minutes as advertised
so in my paper and talk I'm focusing on
a particular aspect of Algeria relations
with United States in the early 70s
particularly with regards to the oil and
gas sector and it's an interesting
period of time because since Algerian
independence in 1962 the two countries
out here in the US have had generally
not agreed on economic matters or on
political matters out years or more
prominent radical third world countries
that which are be very critical of the
u.s. position in the world in its
economic position or the interesting
developments that have of this sort of
on a wild oscillation in the early
seventies family whereby in 1971 in
febrile 1951 the Algerians the Algerian
government nationalized their oil and
gas industries largely at the expense of
French companies which have dominated
the sector since independence and this
coincided with the Algerians forming new
agreements with American companies in
particular which were on more favorable
terms of the other Algeria's in terms of
paper that they wanted to be as the
model for their or the gas sectors
moving forward in what the ingredients
are first signed in 68 and 69 million
land in 1971 so in effect the others
were sort of substituting you a u.s.
role for a French roll in the oil and
gas sector at the time were even many
and that the president said that we
adopt dogmatic the world goes much too
fast for theories and this is no longer
in 1917 this is a time when men are
going to other planets and we have
chosen realism as our method so he was
saying this he was addressing well both
an American and Algerian audience in
this case essentially justify what
seemed to be a sort of reversal of the
Algerian government's ideological
position of the past 10 10 years and I
think it's a very interesting moment
because it's not the oil and gas sector
per say that I'm interesting but I think
it comes at the intersection of a lot of
broad changes in the international
system on the one hand there is
date aunt in a cold war sense i think
what we made into say can say that the
world is waiting to pass my theories or
it not dogmatic he's signaling as sort
of a sort of date on easily the third
world and the United States a sort of
ideological de-escalation in between
north and south as well at least so he
says and I think it also coincides with
important structural changes in the
global economy where by the Western
economies the economy particular is
starting to have great difficulties in
the 1970s is a period that the global
economy changes substantially comes out
in the 1980s a rather different
structures and what's interesting about
this period is that this sort of seems
to be almost the pinnacle of the third
world is moment in an economic sense
algeria as we will establish now being
the pivotal third world stage all in a
gas being crass the pivotal of third
world is so clear world's commodities
and so why does i'm interested why just
at the moment that why does the third
world is economic project seem to be at
its peak right before it becomes i have
noted and seems that fails greatly as
most we could read in the 1980s so i
want to sort of zero in on the history
of algerian US relations regarding
economics and other gas a particular
time look at these bigger issues through
this narrower lens and the first thing
the key to the algeria newest
relationship in my view is the sense
that in a sense algerian nationalism
developed and matured and jared
independence was gained essentially in a
period of the American Imperium or
American economic and political economy
and this is interesting as a result of
is essentially the Algerians have an
interesting ambivalence
American power that perhaps is
encapsulated in India one of the main
museums the Museum of the National Army
of algeria's which essentially the whole
museum is a is a testament to the
algerian national identity and try to
establish a nationalist history for the
country a one of the prized pieces there
now is a treaty signed in 1815 the
american government and the ottoman dey
of algiers at the time because the
Americans came across and shelled
Algiers and the Ottoman de agreed to
essentially stopped our veins on
American shipping so this seems like it
not necessarily something that the
Algerians should be because it
commemorates essentially their military
defeat by the American Navy but it's
also proves a nerve you bet and Algeria
some sort of Algerian polishing existed
before French colonization so I think it
sort of epitomizes on the one hand there
their need for American power but on the
other hand there a certain resentment of
as well I'm so throughout the American
power made a great impression on the
algerian national movement of World War
two because the American army invaded
North Africa to defeat the meeting
French forces in Algiers of North Africa
so is that point for that the Algerian
not just move it as a core piece of
their strategy to orbit dependent 154
262 was appealing to American power the
American invasion in the Second World
War had proved to them that there was a
far more powerful force at their than
France superior in economic terms and
military terms of technological terms
and that they were hoping that they
would essentially appeal to the united
states of the u.s. eventually the
arbiter would force france to release
algeria so that's one aspect of them
feeling that state they need United
States I think this sense remains after
independence another important impact on
Algerian nationalism of the quote
unquote
American imperium and putting it is the
emphasis on economics and development
because the war of independence is
happening at a time when the Cold War's
talking very much about economic issues
there's a massive consumer revolution in
France itself is sort of the backdrop
between the French in the Frank
luxuriant paradigm to the War of
Independence Nixon Kissinger kitchen
debates and so in the latter stages of
the war of independence becomes very
much about economic issues with the
French and the FLN promising Algerians
that they were they were the ones who
would deliver more material prosperity
and economic development and as a result
after independence there was two main
prongs to the Algerian economic strategy
I think the first hand is the first is
oil and gas which was discovered during
the War of Independence in the Sahara
and the ITV Algerians would like oil and
gas to be the motor of their
industrialization and development not
just in terms of export revenues but
they talk what I need they would like it
to be not just a source of cash but to
use the oil and gas sectors essentially
was the skeleton upon which further
industrialization and development would
be built as this being the
infrastructure that you would around
sort of distribution and gas
liquification plans and so on this way
this would give rise to a sort of
organic industrialization program apart
from just getting large amounts of money
for actually exporting these goods and
then the second prong of Algerian
economic strategy was diversification
trying to reduce Frances dominant role
in just about every aspect of their
economy or the gas in particular and so
the United States played into this fat
in the sense that although the Algerians
were very suspicious and generally
hostile to the American economic role in
the world on the other hand their
immediate even after independence their
immediate Imperial foe in economic terms
as France whereas the US or thought they
saw it as a perhaps the greatest
imperial power was a more dis
then particularly their particular
situation it was a more disappointment
this one is the lesser of two imperior
evils Imperial evils if you will so in
during the 1960's after independence the
alternative will try to attract us
interest in the Algerian economy to get
us businesses to start to supplant
French businesses essentially give them
alternative sources of trade beside
France which doesn't really work in the
early mid 1960s partly because the US
government doesn't want to be in the
position of replacing friends because
that will be very upsetting to French
government's and also because of their
differences about Cuba and Congo and
Vietnam and all these sort of third
world issues so celeb relations
deteriorate threaten 60s and the
culmination of this deterioration is in
1967 but the Algerians actually break
diplomatic relations with the u.s. in
the way of the arab-israeli war in 1967
and that's quite that's a things
yet very interesting is now relation to
actually program and they will be no
official diplomatic relation to 22
countries to regulate 60s and early 70s
but it's during this period of time that
their economic relations suddenly really
start to escalate taking off from 1970
by the mid 70s in fact the US will have
replaced France as elders chief trading
partner which is very dramatic reversal
of fortune given the history that just
summated here and there's there's I
think there's a few reasons for this
okay the first being that I think there
is a reversal there's complimentary
changes in American and Algerian
thinking perhaps on the American side I
think there's essentially a less
ideological economic engage
with the third world where by for
example Kennedy and Johnson network
emphasized sort of trying to get third
competing ideologically for the correct
development models with the Soviet Union
and the Chinese in the third world and I
think this is a much smaller agenda for
the Nixon administration also the Nixon
administration think had a sense a
newfound sense of American economic
weakness and Nixon spoke in terms of the
United States almost sort of becoming a
new room or Greece or a fading Empire
there was in nineteen seventy was the
pinnacle of American oil production at
that point onwards the United States
becomes a net importer of oil and gas
and this is a point at which energy
security and all these sort of things
that people talk about a lot today again
start to be discussed a lot in the
United States and there's a sort of a
sense perhaps of almost managing an
imperial decline in the next
administration PCB they taunt with the
Soviet Union and perhaps agreements like
the new oil and gas agreements with
Algeria on the audience of things their
situation reaches a crux because their
other main export is wine and
essentially the French government
stopped buying wine in the quantities
and prices that the Algerians felt they
had agreed to and there's very
interesting documents on the Algerian
side of things where the senior figures
are discussing this in ascensions the
wine crisis that forces their hand and
they talk explicit evac you that we
can't wait anymore it's time to pay the
oil card it's because the frame the
French won't they Bowl online to never
going to hurt them in oil and gas and
that's when they it's exactly at this
period of time that they turn to and you
look at the algeria documents the things
that are going to crossing the videos
desk is that what this is all extremely
explicit they'll turn to the america
it's not because they love the Americans
but they're the only credible
alternative food well investors actually
the Soviets agreed fighter one but much
reduced prices with larger monies but
and so that's sort of that's that's the
backdrop to the BU agreements and the
other interesting aspect by the
grievances at their form the two main
ones are with Getty oil and El Paso gas
company in Texas and they give more
advantageous terms the Algerians the
Algerians will own 51-percent of these
new joint enterprises and also El Paso
gas agrees to build gas liquefaction
plants and so forth in Algeria and this
really suits the Algerian strategy which
are actually cooperating with the
Libyans on first of all their go-to
scorer companies like getting because
they're trying to break the stranglehold
of shale and the other major companies
okay and then el Pasto gases are able to
fill these these this infrastructure
these facilities that is finally
promises to fulfill their long-standing
ulterior mission of turning oil and gas
from something not just being a cash cab
but into a motor of industrialization
and developments in itself and so that's
that's the essential to cause for these
agreements in 1971 in the Americans
quite consciously agreeing to start to
supplant the French role in Algeria
which that you sister doing for a decade
and then the final twist in this tale of
course comes in 1973 with the OPEC
embargo and another Arab Israeli war the
non-aligned and various third world is
meetings in Algiers in that summer and
so that's an interesting another sort of
oscillation in the other direction again
where once again the Algerian American
relationships are seals to become more
antagonistic again in 73 and 74 in
particular Algeria seems to be at the
forefront of an increasingly confident
third world so large in the basis of the
last of groups
and gas revenues and opex successful
embargoed and so through certain fees
items struck by the way that the
American officials at the time we're
talking very much in the similar terms
to the way that French officials had
spoken and losing Algeria in the sense
that pump do for example had called the
oil price rises in 1971 ethical area
diktat Kissinger talks about then Oh
back in 73 is being a declaration of war
Henry Kissinger was afraid an admirer of
charles de gaulle it starts
communicating the goals language and
poking in terms of interdependence which
is exactly the sort of language that the
goal used I felt Union dependence to
justify sort of continued economic
engagement in Algeria so to certainly I
think it's interesting because it's
always in their language the Americans
and the Algerians almost seem to agree
on the under notion that America is an
imperial power and as an empire itself
of course then the my final point I want
to make on this is the ironic aspect of
all this of course is that within a few
years this this moment will seem to be
almost in a distant past and the sort of
sense of third world ascent comes to you
very absolutely and essentially i
connect that to the sort of you
globalization here in the late 70s and
80s I think one of the ironies is that
the strategies that you're gearing up
ordering us inadvertently encouraged us
because their emphasis on diversifying
the companies they were dealing with
diverter going to smaller companies and
actually making they thought that this
was weakening the power of the major
angular American oil companies and
giving them a stronger negotiating
position but in the end of course what
happens is that the oil and gas sector
becomes so diversified and so
complicated that's impossible for even
producing companies like hope that
companies to repeat what they did in
1973 and so I think there's an
interesting sort of essentially be the
the third world is strategy economic
strategy was
was buying into a sort of imperial
economic strategy that but allocated
certain commodities as strategic
importance of thought they had to
control access these commodities and
monopolize access to these commodities
and the third world strategy was
accepted those principles we try to
reverse the balance of power and I think
that entire sort of strategic way of
looking at commodities essentially
becomes obsolete in the screen 1980s and
1990s giving us the situation today
where people can neither domination
production or consumption of those
commodities despite their supposed to TV
reporters so much I'm going to bite
thousand brief but still trenchant
comments in editorializing ups and then
this is a this actually really great
paper time I don't have much in the way
of criticism which fits with with Bob
tyrannical management of the clock but I
think it comes out of a project that I
think is going to have a really big
impact on the way to think about la
revolucin internationalism the third
world during the Cold War where much of
the literature so far has it really been
on the sort of bilateral relations
between great powers and religion
movement I think that just dissertation
and some of the work that use right away
here is going to really transform the
way we think about about nodal states
such as Algeria and reshaping
international relations in the 1960s and
70s does it really was a really sort of
rich lion in here where he's quoting
lumigan who is saying that that quote
there are no opposing interests between
us oil corporations in Algeria and
there's something highly ironic about
the self describes her leader of for
revolutionary liberal nationalism in the
late 60s staking out a very conservative
for a real as packages position on on
the development prospects Adagio he had
it didn't find a way to work with
Western capital and in particular with a
certain sector of global oil industry
that was just then beginning to
transform the world oil regime um and
when reading this paper rose and
thinking about the parameters of the
conference I was prompted to ask to what
degree is this a Mediterranean story to
what degree is a Middle Eastern stories
what did we is destroyed by oil it's
much more story about well and to what
do we exist as a story about our Jewish
position in global politics more
generally and I think that in many ways
the Cold War a frame doesn't really
matter on to this story at all except
except on the margins my sense from
meeting Jeff paper is that this
represents more sort of story about of
Julia's attempt to escape from the
confines of the Mediterranean
basin the overlapping of cultural and
especially financial and trading
relationships which seemed to constrain
on julia's developmental options and
from which the new government was
attempting to extricate itself but I
think there are lots of other elements
of the story which Jeff talks about in
his dissertation / book that's coming
out we can able to concoct him to say
something about one of which is our
Julia's emergence as this sort of as a
sort of Paris of third-world
revolutionaries in 1919 1960s with
members of the PLO the weather
underground's with every self-styled
sort of half-assed and the last to a
revolutionary is making their way to
Algiers the sort of Cape hardness as
Bacchanalia of a revolutionary party
that seems to be going on and I think
that that it's it's striking everything
to the confluence of these incredibly
jarring dynamic thing plays at one in
the same time on the one hand of Julia's
emergence as the sort of center of third
world revolutionary nationalism amid
wish pavana for the thinking more
dynamic ways than the venom itself do
his adoption in 1970 of soviet-style
economic planning and its simultaneous a
synchronous adoption of a pro-western
petroleum development strategy this is
highly erotic and I think highly
suggested of the ways that that this
moment in the history of post-colonial
states that that the market is breaking
down on Chinese walls and frustrating on
Soviet development plans and I think
there's something extraordinarily
interesting about a revolutionary
Algerian state using
using the revenues supplied by oil and
gas production which is being carried
out by independent American companies
for finance Soviet style of development
plans and I think that this is a story
that tells us much about the dilemma is
that the third world revolutionaries
Gates found themselves in this period
bernas gives us the sort of mixed
Jeffrey gives us JD gives us the sort of
mixed answer to these questions that the
US needs and desires of doing support
for its negotiations in the Middle East
it opposes algeria's revolutionary
diplomacy it desires to wean Algeria
from its dependence on France and and
also hope the to help facilitate the
entry of American companies at one in
the same time and the period of genuine
independence that Jeffrey is describing
in this lawless is extraordinarily short
and I'm to sort of five to seven year
period where argyria is making gestures
towards a genuine sore subversive
diplomacy that is nationalizing oil
companies criticized in the US on
Vietnam and the six-day war and doing
other things and yet within a year of
confiscating American oil companies are
already reentering into negotiations
with smaller independent oil companies
to basically beg them to come back
Algeria so that they can begin a finance
programs and vicious development plans
and I think that's worth thinking about
about what this tells us about the
transformation of the world war z which
I think that Jeff does a very good job
of doing get in El Paso are not in good
terms there's there's small and
mid-sized independent companies that
only occupy a single sector of the chain
of production and the reason that help
Juliette and and and Libya and other
companies are inviting companies are
getting
counseling occidental in this town is
that they're willing to offer them much
better concession arrangements and Jeff
treat this as as as sort of
opportunistic in some ways it says
Olivia for example wants to make an
example of occidental to display the new
order of things but I think that that's
but that's not quite right occidental is
seeking markets around the edges of the
middle east along with Getty enough half
so they're seeking markets in Indonesia
and Brunei and elsewhere precisely to
break the stranglehold of the Seven
Sisters on the world oil regime and
that's on the margins of this system
primarily in places like Algeria Libya
Indonesia Brunei and a few other places
where this transformation takes place
and I think that that that solidifies
our duties in the importance in in the
history of the third world as much as
its role as a as a sort of fulcrum of
revolutionary politics the role about
Joey in Libya play and essentially
breaking open the World War regime is
just as fundamental justice
transformative for third world politics
is anything it does to provide a safe
haven for you know for black national
radical for black nationalists from the
US and elsewhere that want to find a
safe place to hang out and smoke hashish
I think that that by the end of the hose
knew that wasn't it i think the by the
end of this paper four levels we're left
with with a sense of both algeria and
the Nixon administration's for them do
plants with the state of affairs and a
desire to at least in public terms let
everyone think that they're getting what
they want nigeria guess it
playing their role within the
non-aligned movement along with Libya
which is funding lots of radical
movements around the Middle East well
both countries are at the same time the
line on Western oil companies to finance
the radical politics I think that the
course in a few years this part is going
to come crashing down on everyone's
heads but i think that Jeff's paper
gives us a very suggestive sort of
evocative picture of this incredibly
sort of contradictory moment in on
julia's post-independence history and i
think gives us a deep sense of the of
the vulnerabilities and and dependencies
that Algeria has found itself in almost
immediately after independence realizing
that its fortunes were intimately tied
with the world market with the fate of
the world oil regime and the private
revolutionary rhetoric that that the
market was really the only way that I do
is going to finances ambitious
development plans the only thing I would
ask you to make me say something about
is to describe in a little bit more
detail on how Abdullah is sort of
envision the emergence of a
petrochemical industry if the thing
about using the Soviet development plans
as a basis for broad-based and
vegetables ation and what does this look
like they thinking about fertilizer
production about plastics about
synthetic rubber what was the sort of
vision that they had four for four petro
chemical derivatives and what would this
do for on Julian industrialization
plants and secondarily how did the
Algerian government conceive of its
economic ties with Europe even as the
types of lessons depends upon long time
oil and friends oil companies
finance how do they see its tribulations
developing with Europe in this even more
moving forth Africa and elsewhere ever
there to see it moving more towards
social relations with other countries
which seemed to share some sympathise
with luxurious radical politics I'll
leave it at that be turned over to thank
you threaded so many words and what
you're finished person that many words
but I will try to talk now and in its in
attendance re um I think it's very
interesting we've been talking almost
now for two days about whether there was
the Mediterranean history whether there
was a cold war in the Mediterranean and
today in this paper and within the last
day and a half although we have at the
same time formulated three points of
view now for not only that there was a
Mediterranean and the cold war and
online home when therapist who was who
were the leading countries of it in 12
his favorite they are India and
Yugoslavia yesterday aren't I talked
about that the people thought the state
was Algeria and he was loving in my view
if this definitely it was like Ian Egypt
so that is something right we already
have anything about return leading
states well no debate on Yugoslavia
I thought it was at least advanced maybe
it doesn't exist anymore but clearly not
you're studying the Soviet Union and
it's part of the Cold War so what I very
much liked about worthless paper twisted
I think it underlines the time of this
whole workshop at the name of the
workshop was global called war in the
Mediterranean I think that these
favorite shows how and why little guard
you that that could call for took place
in the Mediterranean but it was also
hope all right because it takes us to
conversations that are taking place in
Washington in Cuba in delhi and many
other places right so that was the first
thing that I liked about the diversity
we also need very many very different
types of characters Marconi Gossage was
a Serbian war foreign minister he was
lovely who was a big girl who gets
replaced in 1972 because he had liberal
ideas of varied because love they should
be going that's a very different kind of
character than kissing tear Nixon or
many of these other leaders I will just
say that that is the first thing that
comes to mind there is a lot of
diversity there are performing liberals
and there are many different events and
leadership in this paper the other thing
that defines this paper
the fundamental debate about what what
non-life climate is is not an alignment
a political alliance and in that a
political strategy or is it an ideology
I think that most of us would say that
it is a strategy and that's how the most
of the time talk about it but what
brings me closer to this question was
the beginning of the presentation here
today the debate about if if India is
actually the second large country in the
mana level for me India wasn't because
they leave it and and and for melee
giver slavia and Egypt are the countries
that formulate the movement and in many
ways defining the other reason why India
for me wasn't always the big second
country was that if we think about what
could be that unifying ideological
features of the non-aligned movement
perhaps parallel to or in addition to it
being a political alliance and a
strategy yesterday we had a discussion
about it and some of these could be
maybe the hair did they or or objection
to the north-south divide in
international relations also I think
they were all unified in being against
apartheid but also their objection to
nuclear weapons in India might be the
country that seeks nuclear weapons
so I think that this paper here under
Knights those debates about what the
non-aligned movement is and how we
should think about it and it says
something about the Mediterranean but
also but international history there is
such a thing as a study of international
history of local history pisser seems
that porn or some kind of an actual
topic that one can research to get
closer to that the other thing is that
we talk here I think in the direct
quotes for example from Washington from
from other places there are often talks
about whether non-alignment for
neutralism as it is sometimes cloth has
a superior political quality and I think
for the Mediterranean because we have so
many labor for parallel political and
historical discussions I think it is not
it's useful to think about whether we
put qualities to these are their
superior and inferior quality top
qualities do we talk about them does it
come out more in some kind of a
conversation about the north-south
divide or about the food world I often
clean like these are some some some
features that are about the non-aligned
movement and there are somehow pair of
the questions of national determination
of what is nationalism
definitions
are we talked about today about the
organization of the cold war in the
Mediterranean or maybe instead of useful
point of entry I think that here yes
non-alignment and de plan for example
overlap or due date the tennis a topic
of this paper at work we talked about
the Helsinki conference which was a
comprehensive the it's a precursor to OC
instead of conference on Security and
Cooperation in Europe i would say that
from that perspective this paper shows
the Dharma is right the fearsome
periodization also the non-aligned
movement that that could be useful but
on the other hand panties are some
things that keep repeating themselves
right 94 1950 lifted 1961 leaves the
discussion of India should be part of
this movement is it Egypt and Yugoslavia
that is formulating the non-aligned
movement or is India in and then here we
have some hosts that I have never seen
before with indira gandhi english making
a comeback in this discussion later on
and to me that shows that yes there
could be periodization but some things
repeat themselves other than that I
don't have many comments about it those
are my observations about the tater what
I like about it is that it will be
talked about international history of
the military
international history of this woman I
like it that there are several different
us administrations that make a comment
there in the movement here in roses one
that shows a longer period and that it
addresses these fundamental questions
about what is the political strategy
what is an ideology and are their
periods here or is it the longer period
and if there is a movement who is
leading it an imitation it was not a
great Rick um you guys want to do the
selfish thing and respond to your
commentators what would you like to do
the generous end up superior Reaper so
I'm trying to argument what I think
india was more important why
unfortunately do agree with me neither
but Egypt was important at the beginning
was also present clear that the US there
were many countries that were active at
certain periods in the Gamma Cubans were
active humans were present in belgrade
in 61 but they were not active until the
mid 70